I don't think we all want the same
things I think there are many people who
want their their group their tribe
however they define it to win at all
costs and they will sacrifice the truth
entirely to to to get what they want and
no I don't think we all want I think
without the taming respect for the truth
yeah that's what it descends to this
next guest needs no introduction it is
the always charming lovely edifying
rebecca goldstein and in this
conversation we talked about girdle's
incompleteness theorem its relationship
to truth as well as the laws of physics
potentially we also talked about her
views on sam Harris's moral landscape
how does she justify her morality given
that she's an atheist and doesn't
particularly like notions of
transcendence or God and last we talked
about something she's never revealed
before which is her thoughts feelings
conceptualizations of that debate that
she had with jordan Peterson enjoy
I'm here with Rebecca Goldstein and
we're going to talk all about girdle's
theorem incompleteness theorem as well
as
progress rationality and the
enlightenment okay Rebecca thanks for
coming on my pleasure so tell me what
does your day-to-day schedule look like
how are you productive
I feel very unproductive actually you
mean as of late or as may be 2016 when
so politics have become too interesting
and I faced it all so a lot of time you
know politics and I'm reading up on
politics and doing whatever I can so I
sometimes wonder whether when historians
intellectual historians look back on
this period whether they're going to see
a different activity just because of you
know how well consuming politics can get
so anyway when I am productive
I am productive because I become
obsessed and so I you know when I'm
working on a problem time just flies you
know and I you know I get right to work
and I can work for 18 hours straight
in fact I've when I was writing the book
on goodall's incompleteness theorems in
particular I you know I kind of ruined
my back because the day would just fly
by and I had it moved from my desk feet
for most of it is do you write with a
pen and paper do you write with your
laptop I'm getting into the details yeah
I write with the laptop you know that
was in slow process I it was very late
to doing that
I've thought I needed to do I do
diagrams and all of this sort of thing
when I'm mapping out ideas the structure
of an argument is always extremely
important to me you write the diagrams
on the laptop or with a pen and paper
paper but then the actual sentences are
always composed on a laptop and you know
it's it's terrific for someone like me
because I'm realizing I revise and
revise I realize each sentence
I don't like write a whole book and then
go back to rising up which I do anyway
but I go sentence by sentence and you
know sentences can be written seven
eight times yeah so a laptop right oh
okay
do you find that most of your work is
reading or actual writing where I
remember I was talking to Pinker and he
said something like 80% of his time it's
been reading yeah he reads a lot
I read much less I you know for my work
because he is he's a great cattle you
know he he takes from this person from
that person and he and then he puts it
together and something that's greater
than the sum of its parts I think that's
one of his tremendous talents but I I'm
different I I certain attacks problems
usually on my own I mean there there
there usually are more amenable problems
and I so for me it's thinking more than
writing very looked I'm thinking and
looking around my walk around the house
you know and I walk outside and I walk
you know so our processes are very
different I know this is gonna sound
like I'm getting so much of the details
but do you tell pinker or anyone who
else is around to not talk to you when
you're walking and thinking for example
for me when I think I look like I'm
angry so my wife always wants to ask if
I'm okay and and I have to tell her to
bark at her until they're like don't
please if I if I look like I'm angry I'm
likely just thinking so when this light
is I have a light when this light is on
just don't talk try your best to not
talk don't even
he looks at me I know a reticle but if
she looks at me I feel bad so I have
please ignore me so what are your rules
I don't know that I've ever explicitly
laid them out but people can tell and
they were respectful so I have I'm also
from a former marriage to children and
they you know so they were little
children when their mother was thinking
and I remember once I was you know
cooking dinner and one of my daughter's
had a little friend over and little
friend asked me something and my
daughter said don't bother her she's
thinking and the friend said she's
cooking and my daughter said trust me
she's thinking so that's when I knew
that they could read my expression and
they were extremely respectful of it so
I've been lucky okay let's get into
girls incompleteness theorems look I
don't mind why don't you explain to the
audience just a brief overview of what
they are yeah so that yes as you say
there are its in the plural there are
two of them and and what they have to do
with are the limitations of formal
systems and formal systems which are
very very important in logic and
mathematics are rule governed systems
for proving things are kind of proof
mechanisms in which everything that you
can do in the formal system is defined
by a rule recursive rules are extremely
important in formal systems and these
are rules that you you can apply to
something and then you can apply that
rule to the results that you got and
applying the rule ever and ever and ever
so for example we can generate
the integers that way just keep adding
one to the results you got before and
you'll have another integer so this is a
lathe you can you know define the
integers
completely rule burned just one rose
right after you said this is how you
define integers algorithmically yes so
this is how you know that that formal
systems they have rules mechanical
procedures algorithms these are all
inter twined concepts and and they were
very very important in mathematic you'll
early mathematics because of the
discovery of the paradoxes of set theory
which showed us that our intuitions in
mathematics were not trustworthy you can
derive certain paradoxes and so the idea
was okay we're just we're going to
reduce mathematics to formal systems so
just these mechanical rules that will
eliminate our reliance on intuitions on
what seems to us to be true and just
have these mindless rules but you don't
even have to think about meaning the
kind of thing that can be programmed
into a computer and so it and and
actually from these notions of formal
system especially as it was refined
after goodell you we did get computers
actually so that this is anyway so the
incompleteness of the areum's are about
the limitations of formal systems this
is not a way to solve it turns out the
paradoxes of set theory it's impossible
what you want from a formal system is
that everything you prove in it is true
for sure you also want that everything
is that is true can be proved
and that's what the first thing
completeness theorem tells you cannot be
true for a retic everything that we can
prove that a formal system of arithmetic
is true but not everything that's true
can be proved in a formal system and
then you can try to add an axiom to that
formal system so that you know you can
capture the thing you couldn't prove in
the previous one well you can perform
you can derive other propositions that
won't be provable in that system and on
and on infinitum so that's the first
thing completeness theorem there are
true propositions about the integers it
can't be proved in any formal system and
so and then the second incompleteness
theorem is also kind of devastating
because the one thing you really really
want from your portable system is that
it be consistent that is that you can't
prove a contradiction in it you can't
prove for some proposition P that both P
and not P it's true and of course that
would be contradictions or false so that
would negate you know the first thing
which is that everything you prove in a
formal system is true but it's much more
serious than that because technically in
formal logic from a contradiction
anything follows so you can prove
absolutely anything I can prove that one
equals three I can prove you know I can
prove anything in an inconsistent system
so the fact that when you're using a
formal system you cannot itself prove
its consistency is is kind of yeah you
can go outside of the system like for
example giving a model for the system
that will show that it is consistent so
it's not that we're
but within one of the things that you
can't prove within a formal system is
the consistency of that system itself
that's the second incompleteness theorem
I'm sorry yeah okay okay so I'll make a
synopsis just for people who are
listening in math you have a statement
like let's say that even plus even
equals another even number so you take
two even numbers equals no how do you
know that that's true for all even
numbers you have a proof it's almost
like the way that I like to explain it
to people is like Sherlock Holmes you
have the dead body and then you want to
say who killed and then you go step by
step there's well there's shoes here and
the shoes can only belong to a man
because it's so and so and and the dog
didn't bark because they know that so on
so on so these okay great so now we've
gotten step by step deductively we've
gotten to the conclusion therefore this
conclusion is true okay now the question
is does the reverse hold okay well if
something is true can you always prove
that it's true if for mathematicians for
a while it was like what does it mean
for something to be true and not proved
okay but then girdle said there are some
truths inside a formal system you fix a
formal system there are some things that
we can just see from the outside that it
has to be true but we can also see from
the way that it's constructed that you
can't prove it within the system okay so
that's the first one the second one is
also that you can't prove in your own
system your the consistency of your own
system otherwise would come in
consistent consistency just means like
Rebecca you just said you can't prove a
and not a at the same time yes okay yes
so why does that matter what does that
matter to people like that just sounds
so esoteric to most people who are
listening yes it does sound very
esoteric well it was as he said you know
um we had always depended on these sort
of on these intuitions like if you could
if you have a predicate you know forming
a predicate you can form the set of all
things that satisfy that predicate so
the predicate of like being an American
president you know there are how many
people 45 right 45 people who for whom
that is true I think I think Trump is
the 45th president anyway according to
some people so you know it's a dear SEC
SEC that satisfies well there that just
seems you know intuitive for every
predicate you can form the set of things
satisfying that predicate and set theory
dependent on that well considering this
consider the following set the set of
all sets that aren't members of
themselves
so is there such a set turns out there
there can't be such a set because a set
of all sets that aren't members of
themselves if it's a member of itself
then it's not a member of itself and
it's not a member of itself it is a
member of itself that's a classic
paradox it's a member of itself if and
only if it's not a member of itself that
was a paradox discovered by Bertrand
Russell the philosopher Bertrand Russell
there were other paradoxes but that's a
classic paradox that still sounds like
it doesn't matter so how does this
matter to someone's day-to-day life or
does it not matter well let's see if it
matters it so it is something about
mathematics it matters in terms of as
you it sort of indicate it what makes
mathematics true mathematics is a little
mysterious because it's not empirical
right you know we that's why
mathematicians are so cheap for a
universe can hate to hire right they
only require blackboards and chalks and
erasers basically and yeah and there's a
joke connected to that that philosophers
are even cheaper because they don't
require the eraser especially never you
can't ever discover you've made a
mistake in philosophy but um you know
whereas physicists and all the empirical
scientists they require laboratories
servitor is you know all this expensive
stuff you know accelerators and God
knows what so so what is it and that's
because you know mathematics you know
that the information is of carried
inside your crane ship you know
all here are the axe teams work out the
consequences still this is a little bit
mysterious and you're what makes
mathematics true there are these two
basic views you know one is that you
know they're they're the kind of a super
a sensible reality that we are somehow
being able to access with our little
finite minds and being able to prove all
these things about and you know many
magnitudes of infinity and you know Wow
aren't we something or there's a few
that look it's just it's like a higher
form of chess it's just some rules it's
a game we lay down the rules and then we
see what falls right
and so mathematics is really just the
sign of mindless rule following we're
surprised by the things just as we're
surprised in chess them you know what
can ensue just from these finite set of
rules but you know but okay you know if
we had implements we'd be able to see
all the consequences of our rules
gödel showed that first there's
something wrong with that first answer
right it can't just be a matter of rule
following of mindless rule following
that's and he was a plainness but and
that's up to you that you know
mathematics is kind of independently
true
you know the june the moons of jupiter
was spinning around Jupiter before we
put the telescope to our eyes and so two
mathematical truths you know that
there's just an infinity so I mean in
that sense it's interesting here's the
other thing people have claimed very
large consequences from girdles and
completeness theorems about both mind
and matter so and girdle also considered
about mind if there were consequences I
have a little story about that maybe
I'll get you but it was an argument that
was first published by philosopher Lucas
John Lucas in I think 1964
arguing that girdles incompleteness
theorems show that our minds can't be
digital computers that even in our doing
mathematics we're not doing it formally
that's how we know that these
propositions that we can't prove are
true and that even our mathematical
knowledge can't be programmed into a
digital computer therefore we are not
computers right right right right and so
that is and Roger Penrose the great
physicist polymath wrote two books
arguing such things now the uppers in
mind and shadows of the light enlarging
on this argument of Lucas and so
actually so here's my little story which
is when I was a graduate student at
Princeton my then-husband was at the
Institute for Advanced Study and goodell
was there oh wow
yes yeah your ex-husband was a physicist
am I correct yes Sheldon Goldstein in a
most excellent physicist and so don't
care
was a famous recluse um he never he his
best friend was Einstein I mean that
predated like time I didn't die cited
1954 anyway he would they would only
talk to each other apparently and once
Iceland died he really became very
reclusive and then I went to this party
for newcomers at the Institute for
Advanced Study my husband was a newcomer
when I walked in a bunch of logicians
came running over to me
it said he's here he's here devil is
here and so sure enough it was I learned
later there was this brief opening when
he was a little bit more garius and that
party just happened to coincide with it
and he was there kind of holding court
and I had of course read this argument
and I was wanting to ask him what he
thought of it um but I was too shy which
argument the gianluca's argument that
the mind can't be a digital computer
and I just kept putting it off and
putting it off and then he was gone and
I always tell my students this if you
have a question ask you can spend the
rest of your life regretting I did it I
have always regretted that I didn't ask
him that question
you know what do you think of this
argument said he could have views on it
okay so that would be that's a big
important consequence if it is a
consequence
right right right because people like
Daniel Dennett would say that the mind
is mechanistic well I don't know if I'm
if I'm straw Manning him but it's
something akin to a completely some
people say yeah it is it is a thing to
say we'd like to say it and it's
certainly true your thoughts on that
yeah I am I'm not a I'm not a
reductionist when it comes to the mind
oh I didn't know that yeah is Pinker a
reductionist when it comes to the mind
we are perhaps he takes reductionism a
little more seriously than I do yeah one
of my questions that I had - no no I
just really want to ask this one what
are the ways in which you defer from
Pinker ideologically hmm well maybe we
can I would say hmm depends what's what
what sphere I think you know if it's
political I probably am a little mortal
well I am mortal last but um we are
exactly no I would I think that I think
that we're both very very committed as
you note your rationality and I would
say in the important ways we're we're
quite similar okay so does this mean
when you say that you're not a
reductionist which by the way that's one
of the major ways that
and completeness theorem has
implications because if you think of
society as being composed of brains then
that's composed of biology which is
chemistry which is physics which is
predicated on mathematics and if sorry
uses mathematics right right right right
not itself well that that's like that's
our that's right in the string and if
and if mathematics is on on solid ground
in some way shape or form then that has
implications for all for definitely all
the physics and then all of what's above
well even that is contested
so for example I was interviewing
someone named Sabine Hassan Felder who
thinks girdle's incompleteness theorem
has nothing to say about physics
although she said who said that
it's Sabine Hassan Felder well I
actually agree with her okay okay
well she said one of the reasons is that
let's say that you came up with
something that cannot be proven whether
or not it's they cannot be proven to be
true you can all in physics you can just
test it and then if it is true because
it's experimental then if it is true you
just put that as an axiom well my
response to that would be that would go
against the parsimony of science because
if you have many of them then you can
just have a thousand axioms plus your
physical theory or ten thousand axioms
or 1 million it's um in principle
argument but regardless regardless yeah
I actually think that
open on this first question of whether
mind conclusions about mine follow from
gödel's incompleteness theorems when it
comes to matter I actually don't think
any of these meta mathematical
conclusions and that's what godõs
incompleteness theorem has to do with
has any implications for a final theory
for a theory of everything right so does
in your estimation mind come from matter
it does mind come from matter oh yeah
this stuff is doing doing it all yes
where's the discrepancy why is it that
girdle's incompleteness theorem doesn't
apply to matter but what matter
engenders it applies to
well what we want to know about mind is
is it is it a computer is everything
that the mind is able to do and
radicular in doing mathematics but all
the other things that our minds do is it
is this something that a computer could
do and there's reason to think because
of what the computers are you know
everything that happens in a commuter is
computable right it's all working
according to this to these algorithmic
rules that maybe that the powers of the
mind exceed that and that even the
notion of truth itself mathematical
truth itself that starsky's undefinable
'ti theorem the notion of truth itself
can't be formalized in assists in a
formal system it exceeds what we can get
out of a formal system you know one
truth is and mesh with the notion of
meaning and you know and this meaning
that was the whole point of
computability let's get out our
intuitions about truth and about meaning
they're not entirely reliable and they
are not entirely reliable but we can't
get along without them you know we can't
even do mathematics but you know if we
confine ourselves to doing what
computers can do they're very very
useful for solving many mathematical
problems but if we confined ourselves so
that we wouldn't have be able to do
everything that we would you do need
billionaires so it really does relate
these this because of you know the whole
notion of what a formal system is what a
program is a little recursion and
computable you know algorithms all of
these tied up notions and how truth and
meaning are outside of that circle
that's what girdle showed us I mean
that's big stuff that's really big stuff
and turski really cashed out on it with
his underlying ability figure out right
as a historical footnote did girdle come
up with tar skis undefined ability
theorem before him how did you know
yes he did he probably came up with it
he didn't bother to prove it um but yes
he came up I think oh I I haven't
checked dates but I think tarski
published it in 1936 the underlying
ability theorem um and you know a good
old public his theorem said 31 um and I
think he saw thee yes I think it was
around 31 that he also had seen right
okay so let's get to our skis undefined
ability through hey
okay so believe me we didn't completely
finish up with the other day so I mean
here's what I'd say about like a theory
of everything you know which some
extremely smart people have claimed um
is
has been ruled out by gödel's
incompleteness theorems Freeman Dyson
Stephen Hawking had changed his mind
about this verse he thought it did and
then he thought I did so then it is that
girdle's incompleteness theorems ruled
out a theory of everything so let's say
you have a formal system of physics
right and so besides you know some sides
all the arithmetic that is formalized in
there you also have you know things
referring to you know velocity and mass
and position and its base time all of
this other stuff which you know go
beyond mathematical concepts I think the
only thing that really follows from
girls incompleteness is that there will
be arithmetic improvisation z' within
that formal system that you will not be
able to prove that's what follows that's
what good will showed but this is
nothing about the completeness or lack
of completeness of the physics in this
formal system so I I don't think that
this meta mathematics actually has this
implication so that's anyway that's my
right
just so we're clear for the audience
what does Freeman Dyson position on it
and Stephen Hawking's and then why do
you disagree where's the disappointment
between us he says he's written
extensively on this I think when okay I
think when he was reviewing Brian
Greene's book he the Freeman Dyson yes
really awesome he said look girdles and
completeness theorem shows that there
are an exhaustible number of true
propositions in mathematics that can't
be true and because of that we can't
show is true I'm sorry and because of
this
since physics uses mathematics it
follows that there are an inexhaustible
number of physical propositions which
can't be proved true and I say you think
that that's a mean I say that's a leap I
say that's a non-sequitur
yeah okay let's get to tarski we could
spend the entire hour talking about this
stuff it's extremely rich and extremely
complicated and I think for me always
it's let's first look at the
incompleteness theorem see what they're
proving how they prove it the limit you
know the fact that they prove me
something about formal systems of
arithmetic we can't prove you know and
so in this theory of everything we will
not be able to prove complicated views
publicly the truth about the integers
but we don't need to do that anyway in
doing physics that's not the kind of
math we use it right although there's a
generalization of girdles theorem which
implies girdles theorem and is easier to
prove and I think was by Turing or
Turing and girdle awesome about
mechanistic know just just about any
mechanized system now someone named
Stephen Wolfram who's a theoretical now
he says at the base of our reality is
computation and I'm curious if that's
the case what do you defines computation
as and what girdles incompleteness
theorem has to say about that yes that's
for me to asking ok so let's get started
notice what is this theorem oh it is
really what I just said that the notion
of an arithmetic 'el truth again it's
about arithmetic someone from girdles
and completely the notion of arithmetic
truth can't be defined arithmetic li
that's basically what it says right um
so again this is quite a limit to the
notion of truth
semantics notion of truths that is well
meaning and all of this can't be defined
syntactically that is by these rules of
how your what are the symbols and how
you can put the symbols together and
which sim which strings that symbols can
fall from other strings of symbols
that's what a formal system tells you
right right you can't get the semantic
notion of Erath manacle truth out of
notes does that have in your estimation
any implications on truth in the way
that people will colloquial use it use
the word truth like I believe that this
is true or this is scientifically true
or objectively true but tarski also
I wrote about semantic truth
that is the thing that we can't get out
of syntactic truth right it's larger
than syntactic truth he also has he has
and this is now we're talking about
philosophy of language we're not talking
about philosophy of mathematics anymore
we're talking about meaning and truth
and so he has this a classic paper on
the semantic notion of truth and when he
basically is proof arguing there is that
you
[Music]
to the very whole oh it just froze after
you said tarski had a wonderful paper
about the semantic notion of truth truth
in which he in some sense it claims that
truth the semantic notion can't really
be defined either you can have a big
interesting theory of truth the truth is
it's baked in to the very conditions of
assertion that when I assert anything
I'm asserting it's true his example is
the proposition snow is white is true if
and only if snow is white it sounds so
prosaic and in some sense that's what
he's saying
truth is kind of it's prosaic and and
that's why even if you know if you want
to come up with some fancy notion of
truth
I mean even to understand your fancy for
us and shade or a fancy notion of truth
we're just gonna fall back on the old
prosaic notion of truth you know which
is just baked into the very conditions
of being able to speak at all and which
is in the very conditions of language
it's why we trust each other
when people say things we know that to
say to put forth on a proposition is to
say it's true I don't have to say the
proposition I'm gonna stick with the
Trump right the proposition that Trump
is you know it was elected huh let's
make it the proposition that Trump lost
the popular vote in 2016 is true all I
have to say is I don't have to say that
I'll have to say it Trump lost the
popular vote in 2016 I am already saying
it's true let that's more or less what
what and then if you know when it's tied
up with meaning and it's tied up with
very conditions of language and you just
can have any more injury it's a
deflationary view of semantics truth
this is very interesting because people
have put forth all sorts of theories
just a second just singing as far as I
know there's a couple theories which
correspond is pragmatic and deflationary
I never understood so do you mind
explaining what this deflationary means
the inflationary theory of truth there
is no truth it deflates all theories of
truth what it deflates all theories of
truth just because truth is too basic
you can't have a theory of it it's just
baked into what we do the most
fundamental thing that we do with
language which is to make assertions
right to make an assertion is to say
that that thing that you're asserting is
true and that's the most basic thing
that we can say about truths okay yeah
corresponds to reality you don't have to
talk about its coherent with other
things you don't do that certainly
relativized
I'm sorry I don't bogged down in truth
like center a Peters but it sounds like
if you only study correspondence
coherence a minor amount pragmatism
minor amounts and deflationary I know
almost nothing about but it sounded like
when you were explaining to flip a view
which is snow is white and it's true if
snow is white or that particular snow is
white that sounds like a correspondence
because you have a phrase and then you
correspond to the external world is that
not well I mean it's kind of like
correspondence but you don't have to
we don't know I'm so pleased that I
forgive my ignorance
yeah if you don't have to reify states
of affairs you know that a proposition
is true and only if there's a state of
affair that corresponds to it it's just
it's really just pointing to an I mean
way what is it that we do in the most
fundamental language game that we play
with which is to make assertions so that
we can share information with one
another I mean this is the very roots
the genealogy of language why did
language develop among the species of
apes you know it's because some people
a better position of knowing certain
facts and others and we develop language
so we can pool our we don't pool our
knowledge basically and we so it's it's
sort of just comes right out of the very
conditions in which the genealogical
conditions in which language evolved and
it is the to a proposition is true to
assert that this preposition is true is
to assert the proposition itself right
right most interesting thing you can say
about truth
no no post modernists would disagree
with that so I'm curious what do you
feel like is correct generally about
their sentiments and and where do you
disagree and why so I guess is one of
those terms that links together an awful
lot right and so there is post-modernism
in literature for example and I'm very
you like it because it's interesting or
you like it because we believe what it's
saying is no I don't think so here's I
think maybe in general what we mean by
this term post-modernism wherever we
apply it in intellectual domains where I
think it's worthless
or in artistic domains where I think no
you can get some interesting art out of
it right I think in general what
post-modernism is about is um you know
there are certain conventions that
govern these various domains and
post-modernism and generally they're
invisible you know you do the domain and
you don't think about conventions that
you're implying in doing this thing so
for example you know when I'm novelist
tells a story
you know she's making it up and there
are all sorts of conventions that pull
in the readers and make the readers
think to live this reality and the way
that you have to live it in order for
the novel to work well what if you know
the the novelist
calls attention to the fact that this is
that she is making this all up by
putting herself into the story and so
calling can you know calling attention
conventions and that can be cool I can
you know what your friend is self
reflexivity yes that's not all that
modernism is the philosophical
post-modernism is summed up with
skepticism the grand narratives so in
doing intellectual work there are
certain you know conventions of of truth
right I think
torski that's part of what tarski is
talking about there and what if we you
know call attention to those conventions
themselves showing up there
conventionality and therefore a giving
reason to doubt I mean the same thing is
true wherever we call attention to the
conventions one does it to you know call
attention to the fact that these are
conventional and we and therefore open
to gap you know what would it be like to
doubt them what would be like to produce
art that the you know doesn't play by
those conventions well what would it be
like to produce intellectual work that
doesn't play by the conventions of
say truth and meaning and all of these
things and they're I think because of
what torski
is saying about truth you end up with
analysis you know you get to assert is
to assert that what you're saying is
true to put forth a theory that call
calls into doubt the conventions of
truth that are baked into the
conventions of assertion if it's
nonsense I'm gonna have to believe what
you're saying about truth using the old
prosaic notion of
of truth there's there's and and so you
you you end up with paradox right okay
this is something like I have a movie
called better left unsaid which is about
when does the left go too far and I'm
not saying that because I'm right wing
or Orson or Center or alter right it's
it's just because people like Pinker who
considers himself to be on the left also
see that there's an extreme left and
they want to delineate themselves so
it's pretty much about delineation in it
I found that habermas who's a social
constructionist which is extremely
interesting I thought he would disagree
with the postmodernist he critiqued the
post modernist by saying you can't have
these true statements I mean these two
statements which is well you have two
different truths truth sub one is the
truth is what
I forgot it but whatever it's the truth
exists and then truths up to is truth is
whatever I say - yeah that's right
that's the social constructionist theory
of truth but truth saw - depends on
truth sub-1 so it's essentially saying
there is no truth but that is statement
itself is a truthful statement at least
you're asserting it is that what you
were saying more or less yeah yeah
absolutely yeah yeah I mean if you if
these things are just making and this is
again I think this is hashing out the
what if they said this what if they put
an asterisk there is no truth except
this one what reason would you know so
and I'm sure so there isn't I mean there
is no truth except this one I mean that
there is no truth except this one I'm
sure you can generate other statements
from that you know that that would also
have to be true there I mean there's
there's no way that you could restrict
that to simply that I see I see I see
now what about the power play that comes
hand-in-hand with rain for dominance
yeah
so without truth look I we are we are
hmm we're not my angels the species of
us we've got better angels
we are no angels right and we are we
need something to reign us in and I
think it's us one of our saving grace is
that we we basically do recognize truth
we recognize almost everybody recognizes
that contradictions can't be true I mean
thank goodness this is true because this
is part of the way that we've made
progress I think this is one of the
things that we would like to talk about
how we've made progress but you know a
lot of where we were self-serving
creatures where
we're serving of our kin of our of our
tribe and all of these things all of
this is part of what we bring to the
game right how do we made any progress
well part of it is that you know when
people show us implications of our
various beliefs and show that they lead
to contradictions which is what harbor
Mawson and I would say about serial
truth right needs to contradictions most
people you know the species of apes
understands my contradictions can be
true and you go back and you look at
your premises and you see where the
contradiction is arising and you give up
something and we've a lot of progress
has been made in this way you know or I
mean science itself you know your your
your theory makes a prediction the
prediction is falsified now go back
what's wrong with my theory I mean all
of this scientific progress moral
progress all of this has been made
because we recognize fundamentally
something about truth right and without
that Terenas in its raw power
it's my group gaining dominance against
your group this is this is the very
opposite of progress right this is a
world of you know so without a shared
notion of truth it's conflict it's
nothing but power and you know and you
know that theory of truth that should
not according to tarski
but I take very seriously should not
exist right into this postmodern theory
of truth they come right out at it and
say yeah without chance it's one POW
it's one dominant group you know against
the
they're harsh if you said that no that's
where you end up if the nice thing I see
I see
seeing some people that I was talking to
say that what we need in this culture is
more dialogue but dialogue is predicated
on a shared notion of truth because if
you don't have that then how do you know
that you're making progress in the
dialogue what's the point of talking to
someone exactly exactly I mean dialogue
is so important because some of our most
efficacious or operative presumptions
are invisible to us they're so deep down
in us that they're there they're quite
invisible to us and often yes we've
gotten them from our group from our
culture and all of these things so it's
extremely important to talk to people
who may not share those presumptions
because they're coming from maybe you
know different circumstances I can't
tell you how the dialog has changed
since I entered philosophy and was
always the only woman in the room only
and now how it has changed because
certain presumptions just weren't
apparent to people until for example
there was something I think it's really
changed they were certain ethical
dilemmas that arise within families and
and you know and who do you owe your
allegiance to that are in really
strengthened by women entering into into
the conversation because women you know
are often pulled in in very many
directions and have you know family
obligations or feel family obligations
in a way sometimes men don't right for
probably good evolutionary reasons
that's a politically to say anyway so
but if it's changed the dialogue
so no speaking about progress are you of
the mind that we all pretty much want
the same thing we just disagree on how
to get there and what we need to do is
use rationality and reason to progress
forward or just I don't think we all
want the same things I think there are
many people who want their their group
their tribe however they define it to
win at all costs and they will sacrifice
the truth entirely to to to get what
they want and no I don't think we all
want I think without the taming respect
for the truth yeah that's what it
descends to but I I think that an awful
lot of no I don't I really don't uh I
don't I think that there are still many
many people who see for me ideology
means I don't you know to me the word
ideology is something negative I think
you use it somewhat differently than I
do but I do not use the term just
because it's ill-defined
many people many different things about
I just used it when speaking about you
and Pinker because I thought you might
want another yes I mean to me it is a
negative word it's a kind of sacred
truth thing you know that there are
certain truths that I'm just not going
to ever give up even if they were
empirically dogmatism looped you know
even if there's hmm don't isn't is it
different than dogmatism in your in
Europe right it's different than
dogmatism it's almost the same thing is
it okay almost you know but it's a
except that it's a like a theory it's a
whole cluster of interlaced groups of
truths or claims of truths often you
know politically or yeah politically
motivated oh I see well why don't we
define for the audience what ration it
what you see as rationality and then
okay well what I see if a chanel is one
tremendous respect for the truth right
it's a sort of attitude towards the
truth it is a recognition of our own
ability I don't think you can be
rational without recognizing our
weakness of epistemic modesty right and
not only recognizing this about one
species which is very very easy but
about oneself and so developing critical
self critical attitudes towards one's
belief and being willing to do
everything you can to challenge those
beliefs which often you know involves
talking to people who don't believe as
you do
I have changed my beliefs radically in
my lifetime often a great personal cost
right I was born into a extremely
religious family and I don't know how
those beliefs anymore
and that is something I didn't want to
differ from my family this was not a
rebellion against my family and I am
still extremely close to my family but
it was you know an impossibility to
believe in the way that I had been
taught to believe and it is you know I
think that that is you know part of
maybe I'll change my mind someday it's
always open this is always open and I've
changed my mind about many many things
but that was probably you know the
deepest one the one that cost me the
most and cost other people the most so
yeah I mean so this to me this attitude
towards truth towards our own salability
or
epistemic modesty this is what I want to
consider cheeky rationality okay you
just said maybe I'll change my mind
about that and that's a view that you
hold for or you hope that you hold for
all your beliefs
now what about see to me that would lead
to nihilism and I would like to know why
you think it doesn't or maybe you think
now nihilism is salutary or at least not
non solitary but either way what about
saying that what happened in the
Holocaust was great would you change
your mind about yeah and if someone said
that and no well you hold the belief
that it was for oh and then someone said
well aren't you willing to change your
mind about anything
are you really never mind about that I
would hear their arguments yes I would
hear their arguments and I believe I
could knock them down quite easily but
yes I would I would engage and I you
know in a dialogue I engaged in dialogue
okay okay okay how about this how about
it well you have a self did you see one
thing yes let's take heart actually
showed us this is curse medication we
don't have to in being open to
everything and using you know radical
methods of doubt and all of that we
don't have to go through every belief
one by one I mean when they're infinite
number of beliefs that we have you know
just looking out at the situation and
flooded with all sorts of beliefs about
what things are existing right now in my
vicinity and what conditions they're in
but there are you know there are beliefs
that sort of are all joined together so
for example so I have a view about the
basis of morality
what makes proposition is true I'm open
very very open to people arguing with me
about that a consequence of my belief is
that the Holocaust
was an abomination and you know so
somebody would have to so fundamentally
attack my view as to moral truths as you
know in such a fundamental way that the
Holocaust being a good thing Freeman
looking you know what you know what if
you really don't believe if you think
there are the matters is dominance you
know of one group and you know and you
and you want to make your group as
strong as possible right and because
that's all there is really that's all
that's left when you can do away with
truth well scapegoating is an extremely
effective method of causing coherence in
your group you know when that um you
know when Verdun King Ferdinand and
Queen Isabella and in the 15th and 16th
century wanted having conquered Spain
from the Ottoman Empire wanted to unify
it what did they do picked on the Jews
right expelled the Jews this was a very
effective means of unifying and giving a
national identity because I'm glitters
identity to their country so you know if
I would say it's this view of you know
all there is is power and dominance and
dog-eat-dog that's gonna wait to you
know you could actually try to argue
that the Holocaust was a good thing
writing unifying the German nation okay
just the way expelling the Jews you know
unified Spain so I don't think you know
I think their race I think I think hold
taking truth so seriously that you're
always willing to look at arguments that
you know against your premise ease and
looking at the consequences
of that um I don't think this leads to
Neil as Emile is amidst the view that
you know there is no truth right it is
all power like it doesn't even lead to
skepticism Bechet strengthens your own
views I mean come at me with everything
you've got to try to dissuade me of the
things I believe I am grateful for that
either you're going to show me I'm wrong
or you're going to strengthen my
arguments for why I'm right see I'm
always skeptical because I thought in
myself of of people who say I'm willing
to change my mind about virtually
anything so please let me plead those
advocates for a second even if you say
well I'm willing to change my mind about
let's let's take a more prosaic example
about littering okay I'm willing to take
my mind about littering the literary
littering is actually great littering
littering like throwing garbage on okay
Oh a so so whatever the example is you
have one view and then someone gives you
a convincing argument and you want to
cheat and then so you change your mind
maybe that means you have an updating
mechanism like you have some way of
changing from leaf a to belief B do you
doubt the updating mechanism and then if
you were to doubt that then that means
that you change your belief based on
something else so what is that the top
and then why don't you doubt that
because that would just lead to an
infinite regress do you understand what
I'm saying or should I just sure I mean
I think we use the same mechanisms um
we're playing the same sort of
mechanisms it's not a different
mechanism for every belief it's the same
cognitive mechanism that we're applying
for all of these things you know we
first of all you know literate literally
just like the Holocaust you know it's
not you know what you release about it
or not that's the first time this is
literally like a Holocaust
oh yeah you probably hear that that is
that's alright that's alright let's get
to let's get to okay let's get to the
Jordan Peterson
okay yeah right what did you what did
you want to ask Jordan what did you want
to respond to Jordan Peterson that you
didn't get to the chance to respond to
him with and what did you think about
that whole debate with William Craig
yeah oh well it surprised me very much
I don't debate people um I I dial up
I hate debates you can understand this
is my home approach I I don't enter into
these things train to win you know I
mean that need is and want to know what
are your reasons I want to ponder them I
want to yeah yeah let me rephrase me I'm
not calling I know the title on the
video I believe it said debate I feel
like was more people conversing and
asking each other questions I don't know
if you thought it was a debate but it
doesn't matter what did you think of it
okay
um so I had never heard of I of them and
it was it was sort of when I was asked
to do this thing it was like we want
three different views on the meaning of
life and so and so I you know I gave a
sort of secularist naturalist view about
you know because it's often said and in
fact was said by that other person who
wasn't Peterson whose name I can't remem
what Moses knew young William yes said
something like yeah that you know if you
don't believe in God you can't have a
meaningful or moral or a purposeful life
you know you know and so um it's pretty
awesome thing to say to somebody
actually but young uh so I heard that
kind of thing before but anyway yeah so
yeah interested in presenting you know
you can I hadn't realized that the place
that I was
Tina was actually a theological home it
was the University of Toronto so I was
sort of very surprised by the audience
they had a home base advantage oh yeah
oh yeah you know and so um yeah yeah
really
surprised I had never heard of Jordan
Peterson either I think he had he was
just coming into certain notoriety
because standing up to for he would be
dictated to about personal pronouns or
some you know something right in the
Kathy Newman video that exploded him yes
right and he just happened you know and
I I never know about these things I'm
thinking about girls incompleteness
theorems or something completely
unrelated so um so I was just really
surprised and then you know it's very
stern talking and I was just train and
make sense what he was saying I mean
because there was this whole long thing
about suffering is the meaning of life
and it's like I'm just trying to
understand what that man and it seemed
to just come down to his belief an
empirical belief you know that you know
terrible suffering can happen in life
that's undeniable I may be even the
stronger belief which I don't know it's
true or not again it's an empirical
belief that um suffering terrible
suffering has to happen life you know
that that I mean I think that's what he
was meaning by saying that it was the
meaning of life and that we need
something very strong to make us feel
that life it's nevertheless worth living
and that he so there was that that you
know that suffering is unavoidable
perhaps he was saying and that's what he
meant by saying it was the meaning of
life and that we need something and
rationality will do thinking won't do
don't overthink it I remember he said
that people love to hear that people
love to hear that go with the emotions
go with what you know and that's also
what he was saying like there is this
kind of transcendence this experience of
transcendence when you feel yourself or
know yourself to be something more than
human human is suffering but you know
feel you know what is transcendent
supposed to mean and you know something
your your takes you beyond your here
here here beyond the humans and and it's
not an intellectual thing it reveals
itself these were the things I think
that he was saying that's what I was
able to get out of that I haven't read
him since or listened to him since but
that's you know what I was able to get
out in the moment of what he was saying
right that's not to be Peterson or speak
for him I think what he meant when it
comes to the meaning in life and
relationship to suffering is you can
take meaning to mean either effect so
sensory data it has a meaning or
implication for behavior so this cuff
means something because it means well
there you go because it means you can
quench your thirst and suffering is that
so suffering is a meaning of life so
what someone says there's no meaning in
life well you do have a meaning it's
just negative what you're truly asking
is is there a positive meaning to offset
the negative okay basically the same
thing you know that that is oh but the
thing that I really um disagreed just a
great is um look he started out by
talking about I mean really extreme case
of suffering fortunately most of us do
not have to go through you know a child
suffering in Auschwitz I come from a
family that was destroyed by that my
Hungarian family can guarantee his
family was destroyed by that so I grew
up on these stories I mean I lived these
stories I heard them said you were named
after yes
every child in my generation and next
generation was named after this very
large family that was like down so um I
am very and I think maybe this is this
motivated me and my entire life um I'm
how does this happen how does this
happen how does this happen in a
civilized culture like German culture my
family revered German culture as a
facility educated Jews do right and so
how can this happen genocide
you
you
there's one second I'm sorry I'm sorry
my my headphones just died so I'm gonna
have to take them off and listen to you
from the speaker speaker because I value
your time your thank you so much great
thank you thank you so much thank you so
where were we
okay let me do that let me just have
something I'll just make it a a segue
okay so you were saying you were talking
about how you felt about the Petersons
debate and you said I think we just left
off there yes so okay so this
transcending kind of experience that
just sort of reveals itself when you
feel you know you're you are in touch
with something transcendent that makes
you transcendent you know that there's
you're you know larger than like
something more than people who don't
have this experience this is there's a
very intoxicating feeling I know
extremely wary of it that because you
know I think that it's that that that is
Hartley that is a mechanism that can go
very wrong morally wrong and people who
not to put too fine a point in it the
Nazis preached just such a thing when
you were at these nerve if these at
these rallies and you were part of this
greater greater than you know the
destiny of the German people you know
and it's it was just self revealing and
it says you know was such a powerful
feeling it's a kind of religious feeling
I mean religion has can happen as well
when you feel yourself chosen by God or
God is with you know and it's just a
sort of self revelatory feeling I mean
sometimes it can be in self lifting and
urine
you're more than human I hate anything
that makes us more than you I'm very
wary of it
I know it's enchantments I know it's
intoxications I think human is enough
really use enough understanding your
humanity and the humanity of everybody
else and how the same we are that's a
much safer way to feel and and and it is
it's it's it's there's nothing
grandiose is nothing self-deceptive
about it it is so anyway I I'm all of my
alarms were going off between these two
people between these two men both of
whom know I think I realized that I was
one never mind I don't know anything
I've got there but I don't have really
sound grounds to okay so but you know on
the one side you know somebody saying
you know believe it's I do or your life
is you can't even world creature you
know you can't have no meaning you can
have no purpose and on the other side
they sort of like you know self you know
this transcendence that reveals itself
and and it reveals itself and it the
experience itself so when somebody tries
to talk you out of it or something
look this is taking you in a wrong place
no it is self proofing
self-authenticating this this is anti
rational and this is for me danger so
both of these people all my alarms were
going off ah this is precisely these are
the things I don't believe in
and I and I see dangers in both of these
sorts of things
I see suffering suffering coming from
from trusting your feelings of self
transcendence or danger coming from
thinking here that this way is morality
other people can't be moral right which
makes them less than you so either be
more than human or you're less than
human
I okay I think I've said enough I don't
believe I this is goes against
everything I believe in
I see I see now with respect to morality
are you more of a Sam Harris type that
would say that we can derive morality
from something objective or scientific
or fact-based
I am more with Harris than not that is I
believe morality is objective yes I do
I don't think it is the same thing as
science I don't think that and I'm not a
utilitarian as a matter of fact I don't
I don't hold by that theory of morality
I think that perhaps Sam I haven't
discussed this with him I would like to
discuss it with him more is too hasty to
go from morality has to do with human
well-being to utilitarianism Wright said
that there there there are other
alternatives not where you dismiss human
well-being I think he says about Rawls a
Content theory that I take quite
seriously that it is it's it's us it's
separate from it doesn't think of human
well-being it this is not true this is
certainly not true but it does you know
there are other alternates you can think
that morality is objective but it has to
do with human flourishing flourishing of
all
and not being a utilitarian and there
are tremendous problems with
utilitarianism I do think there's a way
of deriving you know epochs and the
fundamental fact of ethics which is the
equitable distribution of mattering over
all humans which is not to say that only
humans matter but it is to say that all
humans matter right other things to
other sentient creatures matter to you
the planet works of art matter also sees
matter that aren't humans but that all
humans do matter and that's where we get
into some of the problems with
utilitarianism you know can you
sacrifice an innocent if it's going to
be good for the you know in general it's
gonna maximize well-being for everybody
or there's some things that just can't
you know it's a fundamental fact of
everybody's matter in the way that we
know ourselves to matter and certainly
ones that we love matter then we run
into certain problems with
utilitarianism but so anyway that's
basically all I would say I take moral
theory is very very difficult
how does happen how is it how our morals
objective like how does one make an
objective case for morality okay um
there are certain fundamental just a
victorie principles that we use in logic
in the rules of deduction in empirical
thinking the rules of induction and
abduction that give us the concepts of
evidence right and deduction that gives
us the concepts of proving things you
know of logical consequence
and also in impractical reason right in
in pursuing our lives and we justify was
the kind of content argument we cannot
justify any of these just of Kotori
principles because they are the means by
which we justify in these various fields
if I try to prove logic I'm gonna have
to use logic it's gonna be circular
that's where Descartes got himself into
the famous Cartesian Circle um David
Hume great an Enlightenment thinker
showed us that empirical reasoning you
know just thinking that the universe is
lot alike and so using certain
observable things as evidence for these
laws on the basis of which we make
predictions which we use in both
induction and abduction inference to the
best explanation they that presumption
that underlies all of this scientific
reasoning cannot itself be justified
because you can't justify it through
deductive reasoning not up I mean I
can't use empirical reasoning because
empirical reasoning presumes the normal
logical nature you know that nature is a
lot alike you know that there are laws
exactly fine and anomaly as Newtonian
physics doesn't accord with their
observations we don't say oh well maybe
a nature is just not no like no we go
back when six our approximation of what
the lots of nature are these you know in
all of our reasoning in logic and
empirical reason we there are certain
things look we these are the principles
that we are using and we can't pursue a
coherent life with
using them right in practical reason as
well I cannot pursue my life without
thinking you know that I matter you know
if that in my pain matters you know that
if I'm so you know it's if I put my hand
on a hot rate it hurts
I've got reason right to remove it or I
you know if something's going to be good
for me in the future you know then I
launch my plans and try to get there you
know and then and then all of my
emotions as well you know it's it's all
wrapped up you know what I feel
frustrated or happy or gratified hopeful
or fearful or anything all of this is
all presuming you know my life matters
so you know in some sense I can step
outside of my life and say yeah it
doesn't really matter um you know maybe
I'll decide it does it and then I'm
going to go into some sort of nihilistic
funk cuz my mattering matters to me so
much even thinking that I don't matter
you know is going to you know get me
into a funk you know because that itself
is a testament to how much you know we
all our lives
never trust we can't pursue them without
that sort of the kind of just at the
Katori mechanism that we use in pursuing
our lifes we can't coherently pursue our
lives just as but that logic or that
empirical reason we can't pursue or lies
without feeling that we I think you
might think well what is it about me
that makes me matter so much I mean I
can't possibly be sure that I'm just me
because everybody else feels the same
way about them well maybe it's because
some you know I belong to the right
people the right country the right this
you talk to enough people who maybe I
have the right reach the right
complexion right oh yeah well you know
slowly slowly those ideas have been
knocked down right that's progress right
and
you know basically what you would you
come out to look I can't prove soon my
life without just the presumption that I
matter the same as everybody else right
and so whatever whatever mattering I do
have or don't have it's equally
distributed it's her it's interrupts
bethenny sounds more of a pragmatic
approach that is I can't pursue my life
if if I don't have this as a as a
grounding as a justification which I
can't justify but how what is that what
is that to say about the truth it's in
the same category with logic and
empirical reasoning I can't justify
logic right without presuming logic I
can't justify empirically you know are
we gonna stop feeling science are we
gonna stop believin in causality and
evidence and law likeness I mean there
these are fundamental you know to what
it is to pursue a coherent life it's the
best we can do however you did say
earlier you're willing to change your
mind about anything that means nothing
is sacred but then you don't
um it's a very oh yeah
I can't think myself outside the very
mechanisms of thinking right if so many
can give me an alternate to logic that
wouldn't require me to use logic in
order to apply this alternate logic
which is by the way the great lesson of
Lewis Carroll's brilliant essay what The
Tortoise and the hare
are right that is exhibit open alternate
logics will won't work because we have
to use our logic in order to apply that
new logic um that if these are the very
mechanisms by which Homo sapiens think
nobody is going to be able to get me to
think outside them they can get me to
see I'm just that's the basics that's
that's how we think that's that we can
pursue or lies with Albus
that's a kind of justification we're
entitled to anything that we need just
in order to be able to pursue a coherent
life at all you know that the to be able
to pursue coherent conversation really I
agree to some degree but I'm just
playing devil's advocate so what if
someone says the skeptic that maybe even
the suicidal skeptic cause like my life
doesn't matter and now you say well it
matters because I'm I'm self questioning
but that's not what I mean when I say
matters I mean it doesn't matter enough
that I should go on or doesn't matter
enough that pain should be stopped from
self-inflicted pain or means whipping
pain on others you know it can't happen
you know your life matters so much to
you and your own suffering matters so
much to you that you you know decide not
to continue it you know if life is and
at the same time so nothing can be taken
off the rails but mattering too much is
narcissism and that can lead you to want
to you know if you read the diaries of
people who are serial killers there
egotist most of the time so the real
thing to do and you know soaking this
whole thing of you know
self-transcendence and becoming an uber
mansion you know I think that this can
also lead you to thinking and has in the
history in the sad history of humanity
has up and led to yeah two atrocities
yes I'm still a way of arguing that
would say look
the very mechanisms that we all have in
in in thinking about our own lives and
even in deciding sometimes to give up
our lives for a cause or something you
know that certainly happens right this
doesn't mean that this doesn't entail
that one sometimes the very reason you
have to live give me a reason to die
Socrates demonstrated to us in the very
dawn of philosophy so it's not an
argument that you know life above all
but it is that none of us can matter any
more than any others just as you can
have all you know that the this is the
principles that we all have in just
pursuing our lives or sometimes in
deciding that our lives should not be
pursued any further but you know that we
are invested in our life there's a
wonderful article by Tom Nagel on called
the observe the philosopher Tom Nagel
happen to have been my dissertation
adviser all that I do totally different
things than this but it's called the
absurd and it's sort of about this gap
you know when we're in our lives we have
to pursue our lives right I mean we have
to our whole emotional apparatus is all
giving us feedback and how well this
life of mine is going know sometimes
life's can go pretty terribly and people
may actually even want to exit them
that's that's not the point
but the point is you know that we are we
we pursue our lives I mean who else's
life are you're going to pursue have not
your own there is a certain commitment
to this life and then when you think
about well what justifies it the only
thing that can justify it are the kinds
of grounds that would justify
everybody's life to themselves everybody
takes this their lives seriously that's
enough
that's enough that's enough to tell you
that slavery is wrong right those slaves
lives mattered as much to them as my
life matters to me the lives of their
children mattered much to them all of it
was there everything that's there when I
introspect about my life that makes me
know how much matters was there for them
right that richness and so that you know
to actually just come to terms with what
what we are just and being human that's
what I say being human is enough I mean
if we can really understand the full
implications of that that would be
enough right this would be a good world
a better world you know oneself it
wouldn't cure coronavirus but it would
tell us how important the cure is for
everybody right not not more important
for the rich you can escape it or you
know in this country there's anyway okay
you wrap up you just use the word better
which implies progress however not every
culture would obviously not every
culture would believe that slavery is
wrong for certain types of people even
within your own race yeah does that mean
that progress is incompatible with
multiculturalism yeah well if
multiculturalism means not only you know
different morality different moralities
in that sense you know that one doesn't
accept the mattering the equal battery
of all human beings if that's an
objective fact which I think it is I
think that's an objective fact you know
that just comes out of how we
practically reason in our own case and
then have to universalize it to others
if that's an objective fact yeah they're
making a huge mistake um yeah just as
the clinic does that mean that we can
rank orders cultures in terms of which
ones are more progressive and then if so
I think this is extremely yeah I'm not
trying true I'm not trying to put a
gotcha on you
but if so would you say that the West
has the most progressive cultures my
depends what you mean by progressive
look do I think that a culture that
doesn't believe in genocide is it's
morally superior to one that does
believe in Janice I guess of course I do
I mean that's what it is to believe in
the objectivity of morality so I mean as
soon as you say you know you commit
yourself to the objectivity of morality
which I put on the yes which I rank with
the objectivity of logic and computer
reasoning um you know of course you're
going to say that certain cultures got
things terribly wrong yes and rape
cultures get things terribly wrong even
if let's just do a thought experiment
and this culture who's that said that
genocide is great be killed all the rest
of people who thought the genocide
wasn't great and now going back to your
argument about it's a human universal
now they have as a human Universal
genocide is okay and they can reason and
say that well look it's a human
universal this is the way our brains are
built this is objective morality so then
we have two disparate accounts on
whatever yes morality does not depend on
how our brains are built it's not
reducible I think that Harris is wrong
about this I don't think that the
neuroscience is wrong relevant you know
and the fact that consciousness is a
brain process is all relevant to this no
they would still be wrong even though it
it would be an empirical fact that
everybody just everybody bird just flew
into one of her windows
it was a big birds of hopefully survived
you know even if it was a universally
accepted fact that everybody believes
that yes he's the sub-base you know once
tainted our Aryan purity and that was a
worst world we would be wrong that was a
better world and what they did in order
to get you this world of universal
agreement was egregious and was
objectively wrong
those people mattered those people
mattered they're suffering mattered
nothing will ever convince me I didn't
that that is wrong you know that there's
my agree I agree I'm just I just hope
you know I was playing devil's advocate
but then we just found something that
you said that you is immovable when you
were willing to because I cannot think
it is immutable because it derives from
the very mechanisms by which I think
about my own life in order to pursue it
it derives from that you know and
anything I think that's a way of
justifying a whole lot of propositions
we do it in logic we do it in empirical
reasoning how do we do it in practical
reason as well as in moral reasoning as
well that and then and I would equate
all of them so that's a different way of
going about trying to justify these
things right there's no coherence you
know without certain mechanisms of
thinking I can't think myself outside of
them because they are what I think with
so what's next for you work in the
audience find more out more about you
well I've written 10 books and they are
you know both some fiction fiction and
nonfiction I often in the past have used
novels for fictional and I think there
are certain things that
one can do it in fiction they help you
wrote a fictional book that's actually
how I found out about your husband who's
a physicist because I saw you wrote one
that deals with quantum physics and
background in physics and math and so I
was wondering well you know most people
misuse quantum physics it tells like
well let's see Oh her husband at the
time was okay great so at least he could
corrected her if she was going off the
rails like Deepak Chopra I can hear that
that's it at least then if you were
saying something that wasn't comporting
with the data when it comes to quantum
physics or taking the metaphor to to
metaphorically like Deepak might served
as a correction mechanism well I
actually studied physics as well that
was my first major and so I actually
come from a background in math and
physics never you know I would do
something like another but yeah I hear
so I went from physics to philosophy to
physics and so and people who do
philosophy physics usually have to know
good to you're basic yeah but yeah I
mean I have always been interested in
the foundations of quantum mechanics
which is you know philosophical you can
use this theory and know how to use this
theory and disagree tremendously on
interpretations of quantum mechanics and
I'm also always been extremely
interested in the not really
contradiction but the tension between
relativity theory and quantum mechanics
you know our two most successful
theories robust as far as predictions
are made but there is a deep tension
between them and so you know that that
is very interesting you know and that is
said something yeah and the novel came
out of that yes and I you know I'm in
being interested in you
potations of quantum mechanics I became
very interested in David bones
interpretation mechanics very early on
it caught on more in bed my ex-husband
had a lot to do with it
right yeah he's a very strong
well me and we knew david bohm towards
the end of his life and he was a
fantastic guy and the whole thing that
happened to him I mean it's you know
it's a very dramatic it's a novelistic
kind of thing I mean it was sort of
inspired by bohmian interpretation of
Galax I mean so you know yeah I think I
feel bad that I implied like like the
the radical left would say that I was
indoctrinated by the patriarchy to
suggest that that your book was correct
because of your husband or not because
of your own knowledge my bad
no it's it's it's perfectly fine and you
know most people who you know write
novels you know don't have a background
in the more technical stuff it's too bad
right because I you know like um I think
that they should feed off of each other
you know the arts and and the technical
sciences and both are extremely
beautiful and their beauty has a lot to
do with structure and so I mean to me it
just seems very natural so anyway yeah I
sometimes write novels that you want to
plug any website I don't have a website
and I'm not on Facebook but when I
published my last book you know I
completely surround every book on links
to your books
yeah yeah um but when I last book was
published my publisher sort of begged me
to get some sort of social media
presence and so I I do have a Twitter
feed but I don't lose it or check it
often
yeah it's okay I'll still include it
and and that's very very last you can
answer the super super briefly it's
about women in the STEM fields we were
talking about that so do you feel like
women are still discriminated against in
the STEM fields or if they ever were or
less or now it's the opposite
you know I'm outside of the STEM fields
now but you know I did I think you know
there is in general a presumption of
there's often a presumption that women
are don't think as well but you know and
you know one of the you know men are
often very interested and very motivated
to impress women and nerdy men try to
impress women with their nerdiness I
mean I've had I serums explain to me by
you know OBGYNs right who say Minh said
a party and this woman introduced me to
her her husband was a doctor and said oh
you know Rebecca's very interested in
Goodall and he starts explaining to me
their dozen cleanest parents and he his
knowledge had come from reading the
review of my book in the New York Times
Book Review that was his knowledge and
then I kept trying to say oh yeah that
was of my book he couldn't take it in
that that was my book right he was so
busy you know explaining it to me you
know and of course explaining it wrong
so look you experience these things you
know as a woman you do man eight has to
do with you know the psychology and
whatever you know I will say this about
you know I've been in a lot of fields as
I say you know I've been in technical
fields I was in philosophy
manners I guess I still AM I've been in
the arts
I think stem this is my own personal
experience is the best for all of these
things yep there's always that sort of
calm Annette who's mad at mutes and all
this stuff right you get used to this
right and you call me try to explain
doesn't matter
here's what math and the sciences have
that the arts and philosophy doesn't
have to the same extent in minute you
can prove your results right you've got
a good proof you know they can smell a
until the cows come in it's not gonna
make a difference you've got a good than
poop for a hard theorem an elegant proof
it can be checked out with the sciences
we've got reality
we've got predictions you know so a I'm
very good friends with a cosmologists
female cosmologists and who's went
through all sorts of problems wasn't
tenured and then she made some radical
prediction the evidence just came in
Thank You universe stem right you can
make pretty you know you've caught
universe can give can give you data and
can validate your your and you so it's
in the arts it's all much more
subjective and I think women have a
tougher time I mean there are certain
kinds of women subjects you write novels
about family dynamics and you know
that's what you know and you're gonna do
fine but you know I I do think that you
know since there's really nothing like
what you get in math proof or in the
sciences I'm sure a call absence to show
that's what your work is good or not in
the arts it's much much harder that's uh
yeah
so give as far as being a woman
it's better to be in stem that's what I
say does that make sense to you
thank you so much Rebecca appreciate
your your generosity with your time well
I appreciate your questions they're good
and you know they were their substitute
and they're also very probing so I
appreciate that